i'm deputy speaker i would like to begin
my remarks by echoing the words of the
prime minister
the scale of the suffering this virus
has inflicted is truly heartbreaking
and my thoughts are with those who have
tragically lost loved ones
yesterday madden deputy speaker when i
addressed the house i said the
government's focus
is on protecting the uk's world leading
vaccination program a program that we
should be proud of
and reducing the risk of a new strain of
the virus being transmitted
from someone coming into the uk
yesterday the fire office announced
support for more countries to access the
uk's world-leading
gene sequencing capacities and
capabilities to increase
early identification of any new strains
of the virus
this is a vital step forward to support
the global response to coronavirus
but it is simply not enough on its own
to reduce risk to the united kingdom
however madam deputy speaker it is clear
that there are still
too many people coming in and out of our
country each day
and today i am announcing further action
to strengthen
the health measures that we already have
at the border but to reduce
passenger flow so that only a small
number of people
for whom it is absolutely essential to
travel
are doing so and therefore reducing the
risk
to our world leading vaccine program so
for those entering the uk
there will be a number of measures
firstly
the police have stepped up checks and
are carrying out more physical checks at
addresses to ensure that people
are complying with the self-isolation
rules
second we will continue to refuse entry
to non-uk residents
from red list countries which are
already subject to the uk
travel ban third as the prime minister
has said
we will introduce a new managed
isolation process
in hotels for those who cannot be
refused entry
including those arriving home from
countries where we have already
imposed international travel bans
they will be required to isolate for 10
days without
exempt without exception and the
department of health and social care
will set out further details on this
approach next week
and for those traveling out of the uk we
will also be
enhancing and stepping up enforcement
rules
because despite the stay at home
regulations madam deputy speaker we are
still seeing people
not complying with these rules the rules
are clear
people should be staying at home unless
they have a valid
reason to leave going on holiday
is not a valid reason so we will
introduce a new requirement
so that people wishing to travel must
first make a declaration
as to why they need to travel this
reason for travel
will be checked by carriers prior to
departure
and this approach madame deputy speaker
effectively mirrors the checks
on arrivals that are already in place
with the passenger locator form
secondly working with policing partners
we will increase
police presence at ports and at airports
finding those in breach of the
stay-at-home regulations
anyone who does not have a valid reason
for travel will be directed to return
home
or they will face a fine third
we will urgently review the list of
travel exemptions
made to make sure that only the most
important and with
exceptional reasons are included
these are crucial new measures to
protect us all
but also to complement the robust action
we have consistently taken at the border
and while these new measures are being
operationalized i would just like to
remind
anyone seeking to enter our country to
comply
with the rules this includes providing
evidence of a negative covert test
before entering the united kingdom
self-fi isolation on arrival for 10 days
and the completion of the passenger
locator form
immediately stepping up enforcement
means that if you do not follow the
regulations
you will face a fine madam deputy
speaker
these new measures at the border are a
necessary step to protect the public
and our world-class vaccination program
every layer of protection we have put in
place will help to reduce the risk of
transmission of this virus
and any new potential strain from
entering the uk
and as we have done madame deputy
speaker throughout this global health
emergency
we will continue to take all steps
necessary to protect the public
and help prevent the spread of this
virus i commend the statement to the
house